few comic book characters conjure up
horror and then heroism and then back to
horror again better than venom since
debuting an amazing spider-man issue 300
it wrapped its tendrils into the hearts
of fans everywhere with a new film
starring Tom Hardy on the way you may
think you know all there is to know
about the symbiote but venom has a long
and curious history a marvel that goes
deeper than most people realize fan made
the idea for venom began life as nothing
more than a costume change for Peter
Parker when spider fan Randy Shula
submitted what he called a stealth suit
for a Marvel competition Marvel
editor-in-chief Jim shooter bought the
costume idea for two hundred and twenty
dollars and gave Schuler a chance to
ride the story John Byrne and Roger
stern later altered their original
concept and made it into a
self-repairing costume for Spidey before
David Nicolini and Todd McFarlane gave
venom his signature look and
characteristics ironically Sheila wasn't
a fan of his designs villainous turn
saying he was disturbed by the costume
gone wild it wasn't until he saw venom
on the big screen in spider-man 3 but he
finally came to terms with it
grandpa venom in amazing spider-man
issue 333 venom goes toe-to-toe with the
villainous Styx and comes out from the
losing end of the battle
venom disintegrates Eddie Brock goes to
jail and for a while it seemed like the
symbiote had met its maker for good but
of course he comes back venom returns to
break Eddie Brock out of prison and
amazing spider-man issue 345 and he left
something behind a homicidal bundle of
joy named carnage who bonded with
convicted serial killer Cletus Kasady an
amazing spider-man issue 361 Cassidy is
God
roughly a decade later carnage made
venema granddaddy symbiotes baring and
then trying to kill its own Rugrats
toxin in venom versus carnage after
toxins first host was killed it found
yet another kindred spirit and who else
but longtime host Eddie Brock who got
the pleasure of hosting two generations
of symbiotes video game upload Marvel
got super mater in 1995 when it released
a venom carnage unleashed a comic about
a game that's based on a real-life video
game called a maximum carnage the
four-issue story finds carnage using the
game server to upload himself into phone
lines because you know internet in the
90s naturally venom joins the hunt for
the cybernetic symbiote and eventually
wins the day considering dial-up speeds
at the time the biggest twist is that
carnage managed to upload so much as a
finger before the story ended venom for
sale for venom fans have really only one
true host Eddie Brock
but before becoming Venom's host Brock
was dying of cancer and when Eddie's
cancer returned he chose to make a few
changes to his vigilante lifestyle Brock
decided the best way to be rid of venom
was auctioning it off for charity in
Marvel Knight spider-man issue 6 nothing
could go wrong with that plan right the
suit ends up with Angelo the son of a
local mob boss who proceeds to slaughter
several of Peter Parker's classmates
great decision Eddie identity crisis
most of us assume that venom and its
host act as one organism when they're
merged but venom does have its own voice
and it doesn't always agree with us host
while venom and Eddie Brock usually got
along 2016's venom reboot had a venom
finding a new host in former Army Ranger
Lee price and they bickered like an old
married couple venom continuously
criticized prices behavior and callous
violence even trying to sabotage his
criminal activities of course when
spider-man teases it with a reunion
venom reverts to its rage-filled state
way to crush all that character
development Spidey very uncool lady
venom according to the book comics
creators on spider-man the venom was
originally conceived as a female villain
at Spidey writer David
Nicolini explained the idea was for a
woman to go into labor after her husband
was accidentally killed during one of
spider-man's battles her child
tragically dies during birth and a she's
consumed by misdirected hatred toward
the webhead
the symbiote seeks her out and the two
bond over their loathing and hunt down
spider-man obviously the idea never made
it into the comics but hey there's
always a chance it'll come back in a
future venom reboot Deadpool rag2
Venom's mind comic book companies love
to mess with continuity and that goes
double for the writers of Deadpool in
Deadpool secret secret was the story
goes that Wayne Wilson first discovered
the alien symbiote not only there's a
revamp reveled in lampooning the epic
crossover one of Marvel's first major
events but it also gives them Paul a
chance to rewrite history in his
inimitable fashion but wade quickly
realizes that the suit is sentient and
he doesn't think it's fair to any living
creature to make it spend time at his
screwed up head so he rejects the
symbiote worrying that he's driven it
nuts or something just before spider-man
gets to it basically
Deadpool created the venom we all know
natural predator when you're a symbiotic
life-form life is pretty sweet
for the most part venom really doesn't
have much to fear
however the symbiote do have one known
predator in the 1996 miniseries venom
the hunted our friendly neighborhood
conjoined antihero was stalked by a
Zenith aged an alien species with a
taste for symbiote hosts the brainwaves
Zeno failures are particularly dangerous
because they transmute themselves into
other shapes 1.2 even hit out with a
china cabinet of all things species
origin although venom received a semi
backstory and the planet of the symbiote
Sark in 1995 which revealed an entire
planet of the parasitic life-forms the
alien race didn't get an official name
for another 20 years
during his time kicking it with Flash
Thompson and the guardians of the galaxy
venom finally received an official
origin story Guardians issue 23
introduced the client our species and
explained that the symbiotes are usually
pretty nice guys they just need to bond
with evenly balanced hosts when their
hosts have a couple screws loose a
symbiote easily becomes corrupted which
is what happened with venom and Eddie
Brock it also didn't hurt
venom spend some time inside a dead
Bulls head oh that's not good
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love tea
[Music]